foreign
I don't know what could be
more frightening than a world that is
being made rapidly more dangerous by the
way power that is to say political and
economic power is interfacing with
modern technology right you're in no
position to defend yourself against the
uh the novel compounds that are in your
food or your air or the inoculation that
you're being told you should get for
your health that you know
you know is it a vaccine made in a
factory no it turns you into a vaccine
Factory is that safe yeah really how do
you know that that's safe it's never
been done before right
so you're in no position to defend
yourself from these things and all of
the things that should be at least
figuring out painfully oh we thought
that was safe it turned out not to be
here's what you need to know all of the
things that should be filling in the
here's what you need to know have been
captured and are broken yes how often do
you hear
any figures in the media or science
coming and saying we were wrong
we got that one wrong the advice you
gave we gave you was wrong
we are sorry
here's what we suggest you do from here
on out here's how we got it wrong here's
what we should have understood here's
what we now get and here's how it
changes what we told you six months ago
right you should be hearing that yeah
and the fact that you're not hearing it
ought to be setting up every alarm Bell
that you have right and really I don't
know what the solution is here I do
there are some independent journalists
who I'm hoping are going to spot the
size of this problem right yeah sauger
and Jetty did a a piece I think last
week that was quite good he
continued to follow the story of the lab
leak hypothesis in spite of the all-out
effort to reverse history and reverse
the recognition that so many of us have
come to that this in fact is almost
certainly from the Wuhan lab yep right
obviously uh the scientific
establishment decided that that would be
an awfully Inconvenient Truth and uh it
attempted to reverse it by claiming that
it had new evidence that the virus had
emerged from the uh
from the web Market that evidence wasn't
in fact evidence and didn't in fact mean
anything in any way soccer and jetty on
Breaking Point
um went after it it needs continued to
be quite dogged on this on the other
hand I think he hasn't noticed that the
lab leak story
and the uh
repurposed drug story and the
so-called vaccine story are actually the
same story right that they are the
basically one team
had uh you know decided to portray the
virus falsely it had decided to obscure
the hazard and it decided to obscure the
useful treatments that turned out to be
at our disposal and it decided to
promote one treatment that made no sense
and it decided to promote it in a way
that was bizarrely indifferent to
whether or not you were particularly at
risk from the disease or particularly at
risk from the treatment it was offering
so in any case maybe well
maybe soccer maybe Glenn Greenwald maybe
Matt taibi maybe one of these
journalists who has shown so much
courage is going to come to see the
pattern and they are going to figure out
how to pursue the larger story and
you know the larger story
involves first of all a return to some
basic principles that every journalist
once knew right
skepticism is essential the idea that
there are certain truths that are so
important that we all accept them right
away that this is no place for
skepticism
right I can see Arguments for that in
some quadrants never in journalism right
journalists need to remember that the
conflicts of interest of their sources
is Paramount
a person may or may not be responsive to
those conflicts of interest but those
conflicts of interest exist and they
ought to create a skepticism of sources
uh whose conflicts are either not
obvious or whose conflicts suggest that
that person might not be truthful
it seems to me that there's a a kill
switch for skepticism that is being used
uh that a lot more people
were willing
to discuss lab leak that are willing to
discuss actual treatment for coped that
isn't one of these so-called vaccines or
the safety and efficacy of the actual of
the so-called vaccines those second two
things are touched by almost no one who
is still invited to fancy cocktail
parties right
and the the kill switch on skepticism
seems to me to be
oh but you're gonna kill people
don't go there you're gonna kill people
and as we have argued but as very very
few people other people have argued
actually the where did the virus come
from is it a naturally occurring
zoonotic virus that leapt from one
species to another
or is it a Franken virus that was put
together in a lab
does have medical and health
consequences absolutely because this is
where evolutionary biology is Paramount
as so many places but that will change
how it is likely to behave how it is
likely to evolve and therefore what we
can expect of it but base I've never
heard anyone else argue that actually
viral Origins SARS kovi 2 viral Origins
has importance with regard to health to
human health and so if the if you
believe that if and given that no one
seems to be stopping no one seems to be
arguing that from the other side then
you can go there even when it was
considered crazy to talk about lab Lake
without being told you're killing people
now
whereas early treatment repurposed drugs
vaccine safety efficacy etc those came
already packaged with the touch this and
we'll call you a murderer label yeah um
and it has this very nasty implication
right a lot of so
let's take the repurposed drugs thing
yep
the question is do they work or don't
they work and there soon to be the
question wouldn't it there are lives at
stake either way yeah the people who say
don't talk about repurposed drugs you'll
kill people are not protecting people
what they are doing is they are
immunizing themselves from the
accusation that something that they said
will result in death now if you
argued against talking about repurposed
drugs and people die because they didn't
get repurposed drugs that work
obviously that kills people but the
point is their fingerprints aren't on it
so there's a way in which people are
motivated to stay away from certain
stories because they don't want
responsibility for the fact that lives
are at stake they hang in the balance
one way or the other right they're not
really protecting people they're not
even behaving in a way that logically
might protect people they are blocking
the question so that their fingerprints
are not on the deaths of people who die
right
um
and you know I actually I have it right
here just as you said the question of
what is covid is so fundamental right
you want to talk about a question in
which lives hang in the balance I mean
you've got more than six million people
dead of covet that's a huge number of
lives the question of what number that's
another with number
uh I don't know let's put it this way
it's their number right so
the fact that you have there's certainly
a lot of
with that got lumped into yeah but I
don't even I don't even think it's a
good question because
there is never
a look it's one thing if you had covet
and you get hit by a bus and you get
counted as a coveted death as we know
happened right anybody who tested
positive was counted this way right
that's obviously a case in which you're
in the wrong category but in general the
complexity of biology means that you may
really be very close to the Grave
because hold on hold on because you're
89 years old and your death certificate
will say flu and the point is did you
die of the flu or did you die with the
flu and the answer is it's complicated
right so I mean just like actually we
shouldn't have I mean talking about this
new this perspective study out of
Thailand on um
cardiovascular effects of the second
Pfizer shot on 13 to 18 year olds okay
there's not the idea that we should have
a single treatment that is the only
treatment that is recommended for a 15
year old male an 85 year old woman is
insane yeah so when you've got a a
person who's 90 whose death certificate
says covid
then we can talk about exactly okay okay
I don't know you know maybe this was
this was the final straw covet was a
factor and that's the thing to pushed
them over and some you know some people
definitely died of covet but a lot of
people who were not ready to die who
were not anywhere close had something
happen to them and then it turns out
that they you know they got into the
hospital and they were tested with these
crap tests and you know who even knows
if you know some some of those deaths of
coven may not even have been with covet
because they may not even have been
positive like you know the the
everything about the test and Diagnostic
and Diagnostic and treating structure of
this of this entire disease and virus is
Beyond Badness I mean this is this is
your sort of Central Point you keep
returning to here which is that it is so
bad and there have been so few
Corrections that we can no longer
plausibly say oh boy they really got it
wrong didn't they I'm sure they must
feel bad
right we can't say that and I don't know
I don't know how to alert people to that
problem exactly I mean we're taking a
crack at it here but but my point is
look six million deaths of covid with
covid undoubtedly a mixture the fact
that we know that people who had
comorbidities
were vastly more likely to end up in
that category suggest that this is a
complex system phenomenon that it did
damage to the body it did damage to the
bodies of people like us who are healthy
who got it right but the point is the
more things you have pushing you towards
the grave the more likely this one is to
push you over the fact of their number
says something like six million people
have already died with covet as a factor
suggests that this is not a tiny
phenomenon and it suggests that
something like six million people
um already and it's not like we've got
any control over this thing at all right
six million people already are
Downstream of the question of is it a
food practice that resulted in this
pandemic or is it a laboratory practice
right nothing could be more
consequential than this not only are all
of the deaths and all of the illness and
all of the disruption of the global
system that flowed from covid Downstream
of that question but the entire question
of the so-called vaccines and their
implication for human health is also
Downstream of that question so there's
never been a more important question to
get the answer to than what is covid
where did it come from and from the
point of view of going forward with
respect to covet as I have said from the
beginning
if it came from a lab knowing what it
was that the people who were working in
that lab were attempting to do were they
trying to make a vaccine right were they
simply testing were they trying to make
a very in fact a human infectious virus
in order to study it and then
whichever of those it was we are
entitled to know what protocols they
used and that is like a Rosetta Stone
for what this virus is likely to do
foreign
[Music]